you
all right if things stay this way I will
be paired in round one with Popovic time
controls with this one are three seconds
with a one-second increment you better
move fast very early on to gain some
time and we have that someone said this
is an unhealthy time control I agree
no I don't want to do that I could
probably slow down some spin that night
he came out of there and see going right
here I have that covered
probably just centralize and push here
huh yeah let's break in the center have
a queen trade I want to get my knight in
to f5 Knight c5 I'll just back up I
don't know 5 is super strong on the
Queen and we're looking at this square I
have this
rook takes trip I go here first tough to
defend this vac to tournament all right
we got that w I believe they resigned
think it may be said point one left the
clock okay oh I don't know if you just
joined but I do see Ferrari they're a
very very dangerous player especially
with this time control we'll start with
a Sicilian there we go and get developed
win upon win a peace preserve the peace
and let's expand some and push that
night away that was the idea oh I think
I like that I get that pawn all right I
have to slow down a little bit and
realize after these first couple moves
are in you don't have to go so fast got
eight seconds get a
are soon all right we got the clean
we're going in from 8 they're down on
time okay
whoo it's an adjustment for sure
definitely an adjustment playing this
time control I have not played oops oops
oops I haven't played this time control
in a long while I guess we're going to
play a gambit here huh now let's take
with the pawn I'm gonna play Bishop d2
like a queenside castle there we go on
the Queen oh really that's very
interesting well he's the glue I'm going
to try to get rid of this Bishop I
should you could probably get a flight
square soon or just take that pawn that
would have been fine let's get rid of
that Knight it's too strong 94 I was
writing with my night and get forked I
want a passed pawn I have this square
for my queen let's dislodge that night I
didn't go for that why is my rook going
here over here is where you belong buddy
get to the seventh plenty of time plenty
of time and we're just mopping up some
stuff no he's pinned oh I got to get
that off I have to get that
four right away back to chairman go
preferences game behavior always promote
to a queen and now hope hope that I
could get back into the tournament for
one okay now I was really going to say
hope that I don't ever need a knight in
this tournament
okay well Vic is paired up against
Kitsch twenty four right now who is in
first okay
playing against John um this seems like
one of those suggested names you know
player who really wanted John and his
birth date and instead uh he was uh
presented with other options one of
which was Jen one two three four five
six that's the one we decided on in the
end we're going to look to expand on the
Queen side this is where I have some
space I also have some good coordination
between my structure and Bishop have
nine seconds I go here and try and get
my knight on a for one day now I could
dive and get a passed pawn
that's an interesting move very
interesting I want to preserve that pawn
so I'm giving up a pawn in order to do
that I want my knight on c4 they should
play Knight III they have a really
strong Knight I'm hitting the rook they
missed that I was on the rook so now I'm
pushing through just want to take here
and then here
once they do a crazy night move they're
down in time who they really hunted down
my beep on I needed to pitch my a pawn
and I don't know if they captured the
correct way when I played b3 well I
should say I don't know that they should
have I don't think they should have
captured I got to go fast faster in the
beginning you have some space
I think they should have locked it down
I guess we're going to swing him over
here
let's get him out I guess they're going
to kick my LightSquared bishop plate
like this I guess and get him maybe I
pulled my bishop off of that diagonal
too quick or um oops maybe I cast too
quick is what I meant to say well why
are you trying to commentate are you
really trying to do this you're really
trying to commentate alright we're going
to focus on the light squares that's the
big plan take care take up the pawn now
he's past and very very fast you can't
stop him getting this wits check now
they resigned
determine who over r-e is up there we're
tied is he playing he is maybe um maybe
I'll be paired up with ditch 24 who is
also at 16 and I believe just finished
it was just uh myself in Ferrari won -
yes gets 24 ok let's see what we get
here ok we're going to be getting their
King uncounseled for 1 and I'm not sure
this is a good idea we're going to shoot
fourth though you know this diagonal now
we're winning some stuff a lot of stuff
getting the rook next you've banked a
lot of time I should slow down some yeah
we're we're in good shape now let's get
on this diagonal dropping some stuff but
plenty of time
and plenty of material still up a full
ruck yeah they resigned okay whoo that
was a really fast pairing don't like
that mmm yeah it's really tough to
commentate these first handful of moves
got some time now let's play on the
queenside pinpoint this guy you should
mind I should be kicked okay now I'm
getting in here all right they're not
doing anything about that
I'll take him and I don't think I could
save this pawn and my queen is an animal
oh there is that move go here first kick
that clean away
now I'm getting here this is brutal
hitting the knight and the rook I guess
we'll take the rook and beyond the
bishop I just take here is there in a
pin and I'm fine
giving a pawn back in the end I am up a
full rock not sure if that move is doing
probably just yeah this isn't working
we had another piece they don't and
we're all right on the clock to watch I
don't want to put them in stalemate and
checkmate coming up soon and that's mate
huh oh no I was thinking if I mouse
looked that I might have gotten mated
but I could always block with rook g8
anyhow 2824 is where we stand
haven't had Ferrari in a tournament I
created or even played in in quite some
time
alright got of pandu oh they're going to
challenge it and let's point right at
age 7 let's defend that pawn rook to
half open file and how about we line up
a queen bishop battery queenie for
incoming he could be kicked away soon
he's drifting far far away from the
Kings side and he's down on time woo all
right back to Turman they were going to
struggle because they were really
locking some defense on the Kings side I
think they would in that final position
they needed to play f5 woo
I can't commentate I already know it
they went with that alright I don't want
it the F file to open up let's get my
bishop Fein kettle you have plenty of
time there we go we're going to call for
c5 mass exchanges
there's no Bishop f4 what's that about I
guess we're going to go for this and
their queen they missed that
playing on applying them all right clean
do something good
um only have two running mate yes
oh my most most looked at oh my hand was
shaking right there that guy makes my
hand shake oh man
even big uh pack weed my hand shakes
trembles it trembles puts the fear right
in me speed the speed is too much anyone
else get a trembling hand trembling hand
you gotta watch out for that the
trembling hand Oh Wyn apone open up the
h-file for me let's give a check and now
we're gonna take here and you don't need
to link your night just move them we're
going in for the kill right here is the
threat sneaking in sneaking in oh that's
interesting
oh I'm gonna take my bishop I better
just do this um I really want to make
this fishing pole happen if you can't
tell well out of my way well out of my
way to a knot castle there and keep my
Rick on the h-file is it gonna happen
we're getting a lot of stuff lots of
stuff take the Queen Eve mate soon they
resign
ekta tournament that's really at all I
try too hard for the fishing pole when
you're so reluctant to just castle and
get your king safe in one move and
instead you're you're moving up on and
your king twice ah man it's Castle let's
get all your pieces playing your Bishop
on this diagonal be nice let's just go
here I play Bishop e5 oh I got their
queen now cuz they missed that one I
only have three seconds buddy oh one
second hmm I don't like how I'm playing
this like how little time I have oh I
give some material back because I was
afraid of stuff because I was afraid of
stuff that's the reason okay now I have
some time banked I'm actually up a pond
so I'm still satisfied with that Alright
improve your night it's important to do
that
improve your rook alright we're going to
go here and then we got Forks about that
my route 9 nights gonna be trapped
I just dropped a pond you cou would you
slow down there you go we're threatening
stuff here
g2 he has to past ponds I'm gonna weave
something though these guys are really
fast aren't they I'm not playing this
well at all
um let's just push need to get one of
those ponds man what's writing mate I
got the night oh he's getting that ah
this was terrible terrible and I could
do that
reassign time oh man I was just up a
free piece man that was such a freak
no Ferrari you don't want to play him
right after a loss or ever
aa-men yeah caveman style throwing
h-bonds at me
caveman tactics mm-hmm slow down man
slow down
pinpoint stuff play age six you can't
get to the age file you're gonna keep
the Queen's on are ya can't let you get
at my king oh oh oh my goodness I just
fell for that
Queen h6 oh where am I stand he's just
48 double goose eggs oh no fire 13
minutes left I got to come back and no
theories playing Scandinavian okay shake
it off man shake it off there you go you
got this nice and easy now you've banked
for seconds you've dropped your d4 pun
not really I have Bishop takes g7 g6 you
know what I meant
g5 that's where I want to be trapped
that night
hit him with a fork night is still
cooked f5 I back up breaking down this
pawn here
I'm going to get this and that holy cow
the matter with you
you should have taken on g6 a year ago
we're going to take here though
there we go that's how we finally break
this down pins key pins
push push again and get
their Bishop let's just take take care
I check a check here Wow
had to come down to this and let's get
pushing your pond some give 7 seconds
man would you get your King involved
this is how I had this was the only way
I could have won this game by the way
King and pawn ending see if he could do
it folks let's see if you could do it
nice and easy there you go
you got this no matter where the king is
their king to that 6th rink and you're
golden man you're golden you're golden
man
there you go that was the only way to
victory how I did it right there was the
only way to do it 60 is Ferrari oh my
goodness oh this guy he plays bad
openings that's what he says in his
username ok we're going to point at h7
are not going to be too quick to castle
I guess we're going to have this ending
huh and let's drop a night in to d4 he's
there to stay
watch out for this square no 94 expand
here this little pond slinky expand over
here I want to keep that night around
for a little bit an interesting all
right
let's defend like this and then I want
to trade one rook they're going to
double up oh they're in a pin very
helpful all right now let's see if I
could convert this and I guess here and
here
got the to open files play rook a3 let's
go over here and point this pawn and
within checking okay that's a check just
defend against the rook activity now we
got the rook they resigned back to
tournament ferrari's on a tear how can
you catch that beast 64 he's got a lot
of games in I wonder if some of them are
he's just moving so fast people are
losing on time 58 players in this one I
think he just finished we're getting it
paired up again we are holy cow okay
blazing fast hmm he's not taken up on
back to try and hang on to him
get on this long diagonal rook c1 defend
that pond make them struggle how do you
need to struggle some maybe get central
just drop your
it's not dropped actually hmm Wow
I checked that pun and get away with it
no they they could have taken my bishop
no I'll have any time flight square you
need a flight square man holy cow living
on the edge
get your knight in the center would you
Bank some time already this guy doesn't
want allow any time banking I need a
time bank get rid of that pesky night I
don't know what I'm doing and bouncing
back and forth
there you go create a nice square and c5
for their night it's a good thing I have
a light it's a good thing I have a night
that's about the only thing I have is a
knight on d4 the rest of it forget about
it
Wow okay I want to get rid of their
night still all right we're going to
prove the king position maybe hmm
all right my bishop needs to defend my
b5 fun this is a long game isn't it very
long okay I have a good rook that's
about it the bishop is
flying how about my rook does something
else he didn't he he really didn't want
to go there
he missed I could take that pun I guess
um wow this is a very long game very
very long got a check hunt that pawn
down uh-huh
it is scary we're gonna have perpetual
that's how this is ending really
71 move draw 70 42 38
oh my goodness I try to get active with
my my rook and his rook was there to
remind me hey you're gonna need some
more support buddy because I'm
threatening pins and all that stuff that
you're just not going to like all that
stuff that's just going to bring the
pain let's let's pinpoint that guy no I
get some trades in there five seconds
plenty all right
they don't have a bishop so let's get
him on the longest diagonal I'd like
that idea
flight Square time let's open up his
eyes my bishop size that is and target
this pawn all right am I gonna get that
pun maybe don't know the ending is
really the best for me
well it's not bad but maybe I could have
done better is what I meant I'm not sure
what that's doing
let's get here
I'm going to push that up on let's get
central I want to be prepared to me to
push with push I have a check can I win
this ending I guess we're going to find
out I need to dislodge that night I'm
almost certain of that and I need to
stop him from going here all right at
least I have some pawns like a target
mm-hmm like this one all right I'm
getting that pond I'm getting them all
yes his eyes are definitely lighting up
he wants them all that night it's
dangerous though improve the King get
this guy going um improve your King more
you could also take their next time I'm
on the night in check I could take the
night okay I got this I know way I know
how to win that one he's at 72 there's
just no catching that beast 7244 I'm
trying to hang on a second
trying to hang on a second alrighty I
like seeing that early capture on c5
this guy is moving super fast mmm
there's Knight there there was steak
with the pawn he's not giving me any
time and I can't Bank any time I don't
know okay
let's open stuff up some huh all right
with that I have the light square bishop
I have to defend that I have to defend
that again
I need my queen there that bishop needs
to go somewhere else
classic time burner right there you like
that one time banker oh really
mmm it's a check
oh it's another check trades okay
I just drop
just drop pawns you got me coming up if
they take threatening mate it's their
ruck - sidelined oh they have that move
oh man that where of all my pawns go
what'd I just say
what kind of English was that man I got
their ruck
oh man did I need that ah man let's cut
him off
wow that guy was flying right out of the
gates man I hadn't it was so difficult
to bang some time against his play 82 46
40 man that is just crazy pelvic ah
alright pelvic ah here we go
instructing the sea pond this isn't an
inconvenience let's move forward castle
Queen b3
let's need a flight square soon on the
stake with the pawn how big of a center
flight square he's not giving me much
time alright just want to remove any
possible targets hmm here alright I want
my Bishop here I'm going to target their
B pawn in time it's my hope and I get
the g2 square now they're not they're
not allowing that I need to get rid of
their light square Bishop so I'm going I
was going to go for this let's get
something off one rook alright um Bishop
here okay I want to target there beep on
I want to target the beep on and now I'm
going to get it got it
next is the C pawn we got that next play
here I'm okay with some trade because I
have a lot of ponds and these guys could
push through without the king's help
that's a check let's just take him out
improve my King be pushing and you got
this one we're promoting with check King
here
don't mouse slip here anything but that
and you're golden let's give a check and
let's just
take em out no stalemates no stalemates
and they resigned back
determined and that's going to do it oh
my goodness
86 is a big number that's how it's going
to end he's playing right now now maybe
it's just finished Wow
two speed bumps in a row here for me and
that's going to do it with this Russ Le
Terme and 59 players in this one Wow
Ferrari top with 90 and then we have 50
I had 50 I play bad openings 44 W young
who put a lot of pressure on me in I
think multiple games 40 and there we go
it's page 1 2 3 4 that's going to do it
alright it has been a while for that
time control which is an unhealthy time
control I think that's why I didn't play
and that's why I never really went back
to that time control it is pretty
nerve-wracking right out of the gates
but all right to the 59 of you I took
part in this good games all all right
that was intense
you